laughing inappropriately is what mom
taught us to do I still can't believe
she OD
once again fans welcome to the Conner
family into their living rooms but this
time there was one member of the fam
matriarch Roseanne experi weeks since
granny roses female why are people still
giving us casseroles and why do people
bring casseroles when somebody dies it's
actually a practical gift when people
are grieving they don't want to have to
cook Roseann bars absence from the
spinoff was explained by having her
character died from an opioid overdose I
just got a call from a friend in the
coroner's office the autopsy found that
it wasn't a heart attack Roseann od'd on
opioids possible bar whose namesake
sitcom was cancelled in May after she
posted a racist tweet about former Obama
administration official Valerie Jarrett
actually let the cat out of the bag in
September revealing her character's fate
during an interview on Brandon
strucker's YouTube show walk away they
had her die of an opium Oh or an opioid
overdose so it wasn't enough to just do
what they did to me they they had to so
cruelly insult the people who loved that
family in that show they had to cruelly
insult them and that's what they chose
to do so there's nothing I can do about
it it's done it's over there's no fight
left fans were quick to call out the
sitcom for throwing shade pointing out
that bar had previously blamed insomnia
drug ambien for her racist tweets that
got her fired bar also fired off in this
tweet writing I ain't dead [ __ ] the
65 year old comedian along with Rabbi
Shmuel ebook haic also issued a
statement following the show's airing
which read in part quote we regret that
ABC chose to cancel Roseanne by killing
off the Roseanne Connor character that
it was done through an opioid overdose
lent an unnecessary grim and morbid
dimension to an otherwise happy
we show leading up to the series
premiere ET sat down with Michael
Fishman who plays DJ Connor and he
opened up about Roseanne's cancellation
and the new spin-off well it's an
interesting rollercoaster and then we
come back and everything is kind of like
a dream and then ins kind of in this
really strange nightmare and then you
kind of have to figure out how to piece
that back together it was really
heartbreaking over the summer and you
know painful for everybody and then this
third kind of opportunity is this really
magical thing that has come with some
really wonderful new new features and
new opportunities I think are really
going to be great for fans
[Music]